hey folks this is International Master
David Bruce for chest comm and today I
am going to be presenting for you a
player who could be considered the first
world champion unofficially it was
before they had a World Chess
Championship contest and he was
certainly somebody who actually did not
consider themselves to be a professional
chess player and refused to ever take
any money for playing chess but he was
certainly clearly decisively by a wide
margin the strongest player of his time
and that is the American Paul Morphy now
Paul Murphy's chess development was an
incredible thing
basically he learned how to play chess
as a kid by watching his dad in his
uncle play chess just by watching them
not even playing himself then at some
point they realized that the little kid
knew how to play when he was watching
one of their games and said after they
agree to draw like uh Ernesto could have
won and they said you know really and so
he then replayed the whole game for them
to show them how Ernest could have won
the game and then they realized wow not
only does he already know how to play
chess but he's like better than us and
so he played quite a bit for a couple
years as a kid and became basically the
strongest player around as far as anyone
knew but then from the age of 13 to 20
he played very very little chess
studying going to school going to law
school becoming a lawyer and at the age
of 20 with very very very little chess
practice even he traveled to Europe and
just crushed every single chess player
there so he beat the players were
considered the best players in the world
except for one named Staunton who
avoided playing him ducked the match he
would have beaten him of course and more
if he was hundreds of points stronger
than anyone else in the world at that
point and what he contributed to the
understanding of chess was immense and
one observation I would make that shows
how much he contributed to improving the
general world's understanding of chess
is that he beat a fellow named Adolph
Anderson who was
a supposedly strong German chess player
now Anderson was already in his 50s but
after more if he beat him up he
continued to play in tournaments after
more if you return to the US and retired
from chess and Anderson played much
better in his 60s than he had in his 20s
30s 40s because of what he learned from
playing against Morphy now one of the
questions that is obviously interesting
to me and interesting to a lot of other
people is had morphe had some good
competition how much better could he
have been because I think Morpheus play
was definitely limited by the fact that
he didn't face much opposition and so he
went through most of his career playing
quickly as opposed to you know really
like thinking and putting a lot of
effort into his games because he just
wasn't really challenged that much so
from age 20 to 21 he dominated chess
world and played a lot of games which
are famous this day and today we will
look at my favorite game of his surprise
surprise and in this game he is playing
black against Louis Paulsen and it
starts out with a four Knights opening
which was common back then very uncommon
now at high levels in this position here
morphe should not capture the knight
back because of the pawn fork which will
recover the piece that White has
sacrificed and then leave white with a
central advantage with this pawn here
left in the center so instead of taking
it he simply moved his rook to e8 just
continuing his development and white
took here but let me just show you white
could have kept there extra pawn by
retrieving the knight attacking the
bishop select doesn't have time to take
here and then black would move the
bishop back and now white could defend
this pawn for example with rook to e1
but morphe already understood that in a
position like this the knight on d3
would block the pawn on d2 would block
the bishop on c1 would block the rook on
a1 and would really hurt White's entire
development of his game
okay so morphe knew that he would have
good play here if white held onto the
pawn like that that's
kind of idea that morphe was really
introducing into chess and here you know
similarly let's say white tried to hang
on to their pawn they could put the
bishop on d3 to defend this pawn right
but again same development problems and
surprisingly enough Paulsen showed
himself aware that Bishop d3 wasn't good
and he went to e2 allowing morphe to
recover the pawn he sacked and so we get
to this position here and here Paulsen
makes a mistake with c3 this is the
first moment in the game where morphe
really does something important gets a
good advantage so I thought I would give
you a chance to try and predict his move
here see if Morpheus wisdom and
knowledge has been passed down through
the generations 150 years to you and
found its way into your head do you know
what to do here if you do it's because
150 years ago Paul Murphy showed us what
to do here alright so the move that
morphe played is Queen to d3 and this is
a move aimed at restricting the
opponent's development by blocking this
pawn and that's why c3 was a really bad
move and what should white have
preferred here
d3 red to allow his pieces out even if
it's very modest in terms of the
presence in the center instead white
goes for c3 hoping for d4 but a spoiler
alert he's not going to get to play d4
in time this game so morphe shuts that
down and now white is really struggling
to get his Queen side pieces out so he
fights with a4 and now comes a really
nice calm massing by morphe over the
next two moves right just improving
these pieces coordinating them
streamlining them it's not yet clear
where he's going to attack but I believe
that he already had in mind what he was
going to do to win the game
so Paulson here plays Queen a6
challenging the Queen right and I've
Morpheus Queen moves away he'll be able
to play d4 and bring his rook into the
action along the second-ranked so seer
morphe thought for 12 minutes now 12
minutes was kind of a record for morphe
that's why people bothered to make a
note of it
pass down that info that more if you
thought for 12 minutes on this move and
that gets back to what I was saying
before about how more if he really
didn't have good enough opposition to
develop as a chess player he was used to
playing so quickly because he really
wasn't challenged so here he thought for
12 minutes and I think it's because he
probably was calculating game all the
way out to a forced win pretty much so
do you have any ideas what he did here
I'm about to show it so this is your
last chance to pause if you want to try
and guess this brilliancy for yourself
he sacrificed his Queen and this is
rendered possible by the fact that
having blockaded White's Queen side
pieces with this pawn on d2 for a while
White has more than half his army out of
play and so Morphy is able to conduct an
attack in this position here with
basically just a bishop against a queen
because White's pieces are so out of
place that really morphe is attacking
with two bishops and two brooks against
the rook and one or two pawns plus you
know the queen could sack herself at
some point for a bishop or so so there's
no question that he's got a strong
enough attack here but morphia was
probably just being a little bit careful
calculating a couple variations because
there's one interesting defense here for
white which white didn't play and the
game white plays rook d1 first of all
here's not a very good defense I'm sure
this won't have cost more fee very long
to calculate that if white tries to
oppose the black rook by trading away
his rook white opens up the back rank
for checkmate but an interesting defense
for white would have been to play in
this position here his Queen to d3 and
the idea is that he stops black's
checkmate threat because he can sack his
queen here now even this position is
pretty decent for black but I believe
Morphy was probably calculating and
planning this variation here f5 denying
the Queen sack and then Queen check
trying to come to f7 to take this work
again the King goes to f8 himself to
keep the white Queen out so I think
that's probably the variation that
morphe was calculating in any case in
the game white plays
rook to d1 here and checks checks checks
him back
so you see he's got the white in pretty
well corralled here with all his pieces
so he was just grabbing that f3 pawn for
free with those two checks and now he
plays Bishop takes f2 with the threat of
checkmate and one on g2 and white has no
good defense against this and gave back
the Queen more if you took it so at this
point more if he's up to pawns so on he
could win in a variety of uninteresting
ways but I'm going to show you the end
because he won in a very very nice way
very good technical move here rook to e2
again preventing this poor pawn from
moving and letting the white pieces out
white continues to try forlornly to get
those pieces out and he finally plays d4
but in response more few plays Bishop e3
and white resigns because of the
threatened checkmate on H to even
capturing this bishop and moving that
bishop off of c1 finally will be too
late because you will play a rook takes
h2 check King to g1 and rook G to
checkmate okay so a very very fine game
from morphe right and a couple things
that we can try to learn from this game
one would be in this position the idea
of queen d3 blockading restraining the
opponent's development preventing your
opponent from developing here's a very
very important chest technique and the
second thing i like is here his buildup
in the next two moves preparing Queen
takes f3 just putting his Bishop on this
unassuming square but it's at least
mobilizing his forces and bringing the
rook here again he's not yet necessarily
you know going to checkmate white
although in fact he is the threat is
Queen takes f1 King takes f1 rook e1
checkmate but I like how he just built
up his development with these pieces
here and then when white plays Queen a6
to defend the first rank with his Queen
he's prepared to play this Queen for
Bishop sack in order to attack and just
lovely setup on that so that's more for
the first grade chess Titan I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around
Ches calm